on a une formation qui globalement tient
le coup mais c'est parce que aussi on a
un man à un maillage territorial qui est
assez proche du terrain qui est assez
puissant bien répartis dans le
département des yvelines est avec des
maires surtout qui font le travail et ça
depuis plusieurs mandats donc je crois
qu'il ya une reconnaissance aussi de la
population sur le travail qui est
réalisé
murray joue est évidemment de la
victoire annoncée de jean baptiste à
monica à villepreux pour le modem après
la victoire de richard delpierre au
chesnay et celle de cédric pemba marina
à port-marly sont évidemment une de
jeunes mères une nouvelle génération et
je crois que c'est à cela que les que
les françaises et les français aspirent
souhaiter bonne chance aux bandits loi
mais rien que la manière dont s'est
déroulé le scrutin au premier comme au
second tour avec des bureaux terme
entièrement tenus par des caïds
oui je trouve que la démocratie un père
d'une mairie aujourd'hui plus que le
rassemblement national
on peut appeler ça mitigé si vous voulez
moi je compte quand même beaucoup de
victoires
là où il ya encore six mois on n'avait
pas des guilis de mer étiqueté du jeu on
pourra toujours trouver des choses pour
mitiger victoire il ya des défaites et
des victoires
il ya des villes où nous sommes un peu
déçus et les villes où extrêmement
content de voir la victoire de deux
listes menées par des marcheurs et qui
ont parfaitement assimilé étiquettes et
pas de me remplacer les événements
jamais été malheureusement non pas que
beaucoup plus lointain une département
il y avait beaucoup de communes gérées
par la gauche
c'est loin d'être le cas depuis
longtemps mais on n'a pas en a pas on
n'a pas ces tristes figures si vous
voulez globalement parce qu'on a choisi
l'union est là où
il était généreux voire a
malheureusement à la verrière c'est la
seule à qui va être perdu à cause de ça